kevin o'leary the successful
entrepreneur and star of abc's shark
tank was on cnbc this morning and he was
on fire it all started when kevin was
asked about the inflation reduction act
and kevin rightly pointed out that if
you are going to print more money it
does not reduce inflation in fact it
does the exact opposite here is kevin
just getting warmed up on national
television this morning i'm going to go
to kevin because i i want to start
not on a negative side but i know that
you have problems with this bill and i
want you to spell out what they are so
that we can we can have a debate about
it inflation right now is around the
voters around food and energy energy's
rolled over a bit that's good and of
course anything can happen until
november 8th but the rest of this bill
highly inflationary ain't going to help
going to be lots of unhappy people and
in various close races whether that be
senate or otherwise
i think what occurs and again this is
speculation on my part but i'm going to
invest on this premise
this is going to be the last legislation
this administration ever gets to put
through after november 8th one of the
reasons uh pelosi went to taiwan which
she knows and she's going to be a very
successful politician it's over she's
not going to be speaker after this
midterm election and she made her move
and i applaud her for it it was very
gutsy but bottom line is this is last
chance for romance on policy and then
it's total gridlock and that's a good
thing now as kevin points out yes if you
create more money and throw it into the
system you actually make inflation worse
it is shocking that politicians central
bankers and people in positions of
influence did not learn this lesson over
the last two and a half years
just as in 2020 many people were yelling
and screaming saying if you continue to
create more money and put it in the
system we will get high inflation the
people in power they said no we won't
and they were wrong kevin's pointing out
that although they named this the
inflation reduction act it isn't going
to reduce the inflation at all and then
kevin o'leary went absolutely bananas on
national television when he was asked
about the carried interest loophole he
started to state that entrepreneurs and
investors are risking capital building
businesses and creating jobs here is
kevin in his full glory on cnbc this
morning if you're against corporate
welfare and you're against this sort of
industrial policy why have an industrial
policy which benefits you personally it
of course it does i'm admitting i'm
being transparent but you're telling me
a sector that i compete with let's say
chips gets free money and i'm a taxpayer
paying for it that's another incentive
the incentives drive the economy the
incentives and private equity have
driven the most successful private
equity sectors
these incentives don't change the
returns these incentives don't change
the returns they change the returns and
how much money people like you get to
pocket
andrew i take risk that's what i do
if you want to take risks with your own
money god bless you and pay capital
gains on it but if you can take risk
with other people's money why should you
be getting capital gains rates on that
money
because i manage that money and people
trust me to manage it and that's why
they do it oh my goodness there is no
legitimate argument for
carried interest uh the loophole there
is no legitimate argument for it and
kevin can try to make that um but it's
not real and the fact that the industry
has been able to um to keep up their
lobbying successfully on this what about
millions of jobs i mean you're making
money off of money that's not even yours
wait a second we've created millions of
jobs in this country we fix broken
companies every day we look all around
the world for opportunities to attract
capital to america to invest it here how
many politicians actually create jobs
when this sector gets attacked i get
offended because we do really hard work
to build our economy and we've done a
lot of 65 years
kevin a week ago you said you didn't
want money to go to the chips because
because you didn't want corporate
welfare but for that group and you said
look how profitable they already are
look how profitable the the private
equity this is the wealthiest industry
in the in the country in terms of the
people on an individual basis andrew
when in america do we punish success
when did we start doing that when do we
disincentivize risk of capital why are
you attacking not because it's not your
capital
not your capital
asking you to uh to pay a fair share is
not a punishment kevin no matter how you
try to characterize do not assume that
raising taxes reduces deficit all it
does is crush economic activity that's
been proven out many many times we'll
let this thing play out but when there's
bad policy there's bad policy kevin's
got a great point
taxes are either used as an incentive or
as a punishment and at the end of the
day if we are going to target the
world's most successful entrepreneurs
and investors you're going to
disincentivize the investment of capital
and the continued creation of jobs if we
continue to watch this play out we now
live in a country where more than 50
of some people's income is actually
going to pay taxes
they get paid less for their work
than the government and so
as tail as old as time
taxes what should be the right rate who
should get charged what and when should
you have to pay it
the debate continues kevin o'leary's got
a great point here
if we want innovation we want job
creation then we should probably go
ahead and empower entrepreneurs and
investors to continue taking risks to
continue experimenting and to continue
driving innovation because as we know
that comes from the private sector
and as we've seen time and time again
entrepreneurs solve the problems that
society needs most hey you did you like
this video great make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time